notre ami a beaucoup souffert là d'où il
vient
il va falloir en 3 de soins c'est ce que
nous faisons de mieux ici au de belfast
[Musique]
tu voudrais les saluer il est magnifique
c'est la première fois qu'il réagit
comme ça avec quelqu'un tu dois avoir un
temps fou
[Musique]
je serai de retour d'ici peu
veille sur lui pour brad d'accord tu te
tue vraiment de cet éléphant
ouais mon père est parti se battre
adam austin tadla qui je m'appelle
tonnes qu'est-ce qui se passe le zoo est
fermée aujourd'hui tu n'a rien à faire
ici aujourd'hui tu attends
ah ah
je me dois de suivre les ordres au cas
où les animaux s'échappe lors des
bombardements
vous approchez pas de poster je devrais
faire sortir
ce soir pour booster mais bien plus gros
que ce à quoi je m'attendais
madame austin et moi c'est un éléphant
des êtres août à l'espace rougeau tout
le monde va se mettre à la recherche de
boston
s'il le retrouve un jour
je tombe
[Musique]
sommes à la recherche d'un élément
on va se faire tuer
on forme une équipe finissant ce qu'on a
commencé
quand cette fois j'ai participé à cette
aventure unique
[Musique]
je n'oublierai jamais